Natasha and I have known each other
since we worked together as kids.
I love her,
and it turns out we both love something in common.
The crossword puzzle.
Crossword puzzle.
Yep. Mm-hm.
And so we're gonna play a game,
and we're about to team up to solve
a movie themed crossword puzzle.
And it's time for Lights, Camera, Crossword.
Yeah!
(audience applauds)
All right, here to read us the clues,
our very own Ross Mathews.
That's right.
I'm here.
(audience applauds)
I take this very seriously.
Now, here are the rules you ladies have one minute
and one minute only on the clock to solve seven
movie-themed crossword clues.
What?
Yeah.
It's a thinking, it's slow.
It should be like 17 minutes.
Oh my God.
They'll cut it out later.
Your time, but if you get stumped,
I will reveal a letter in the word.
So just keep guessing until you get it,
'cause there's no passing.
All right?
Oh my God, no passing?
It sounds like
That's not even a crossword.
Wheel Of Fortune,
meets crosswords.
Okay.
This just became harrowing, but let's do it.
This is not crossword, this is Rossword
and there are rules around here.
But we also have prizes,
cause Natasha, I know you're an avid ice cream fan.
Yes, that's one of my major things.
Yes.
All right.
So if you get all seven correct in one minute,
you and our entire studio audience
is gonna go home with a prize,
a $150 gift card to low calorie ice cream from Nick's.
Hey!
(audience applauds)
I didn't know there was such a thing
as low calorie ice cream.
All right, so ice cream is on the line
for the entire audience.
Let's get started.
Let's give them what they want.
Time is on the clock, right here.
Here is your first one, it's two across.
This fluffy S'more ingredient
got busted by Dan Ackroyd and company-
Marshmallow?
In 1984.
The Stay Puft Marshmallow Man?
Marshmallow, we'll take marshmallow.
You said marshmallow, I will accept it.
(audience applauds)
All right.
Oh look.
Good, good, good.
Now here's five down.
The clue is a type of fiction,
also the lumpy stuff in orange juice.
Pulp.
(bell pings)
Pulp is the correct answer.
Four across, the most seductive "American Pie" flavor,
according to Jim.
Apple?
Yeah.
Apple is correct.
(bell pings)
Six down, number of states and Lucy's first dates.
Huh?
I don't get the question.
50.
Oh 50, 50, 50.
By the way, that Lucy.
I was thinking Lucille Ball
Seven across, surname of actor who famously ad libbed,
"Here's Johnny".
Jack Nicholson.
Yes!
Nicholson.
(bell pings)
Three across, 10 seconds left.
It's what made Gretchen Wiener's hair
so big in "Mean Girls".
I don't know, a mousse? A gel?
First letter is S.
[Audience Members] Secrets.
Secrets.
(klaxon buzzes)
The answer is secrets.
(bell pings)
All right, hold on.
Oh!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh wait, no, there's more.
Oh, you missed.
We didn't get to, 'cause you ran out of time.
One down, the clue is you might find Meg Ryan
and Tom Hanks at the top of this building.
Empire State Building!
Which would've been the correct answer,
but you only got six outta seven.
Oh right?
Wow.
But, guess what?
You still won,
'cause everyone's going home
with Nick's ice cream gift card, $150.
(audience applauds)
Come on, you gotta give it away.
They said it couldn't be done.
Ladies and gentlemen, Natasha.
You can catch Natasha
(audience applauds)
in the new season of "Russian Doll",
streaming on Netflix, one of the greatest shows.
(bright theme music)